[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 27
novembre les documentaires vont vous
faire voyager pour sa quatrième édition
le festival saint quentin vous emmène
dans l'espace la conquête spatiale
n'aura plus de secret grâce aux
projections aux ateliers et aux
rencontres 70 auteurs sont attendus à
elancourt la commanderie accueille la
deuxième édition du salon du livre de la
commune
l'histoire et la littérature seront à
l'honneur protéger conserver et
restaurer le patrimoine chaque année
plusieurs oeuvres sont prises en charge
dans le département l'occasion de
découvrir cette mission des personnes en
fauteuil électrique des amateurs et des
danseurs professionnels tous regroupés
pour une histoire celle d'une bande de
carnaval depuis plus de trois ans le
théâtre du sable black blanc beur et
vivre debout imagine confrontent leur
monde
trois ans de travail qui voit naître un
spectacle et joue l'histoire de nos
histoires
le 29 novembre à l'espace albert camus
de maurepas
[Musique]
ils vous font entrer dans la danse dans
une farandole sans fin pour vous conter
leur histoire sur scène les comédiens
les danseurs les interprètes vous
raconte des bouts de vie la leur pris en
compte est né en 2014 pour les 40 ans de
l'association vivre debout
il a fallu que j'apprenne qu'on apprenne
pardo a à jouer à faire du théâtre même
si l'expression n'est pas très très très
joli à danser à se mouvoir sur cède donc
là on a mis en place des ateliers on
s'est appauvrie apprivoiser mutuellement
on a appris à se connaître on a appris à
ne plus avoir peur de l'autre et à
travailler ensemble et avec nos
différences nous fait dur tout le monde
à des figures même si on passe d'une
personne valide
elle a forcément au fond d'elle
peut-être quelque chose de cassé trois
ans et demi de travail pour une marmite
à trois pieds comme ils peuvent se
surnommer des personnes handicapées au
contact de comédiens amateurs et de
professionnels
quand vivre debout lance l'idée le
théâtre du sable et la compagnie black
blanc beur n'hésite pas le 19 octobre je
crois 2014
on a fait dans ce riche dans cette école
une petite soirée qui en fait n'a pas pu
s'arrêter quoi s'ils acceptent sa
relance est en fait en fait et je peux
le dire maintenant comme ça un peu le
récit le récit au local quoi les gens se
fabriquer des histoires sur les
remonterait se connaissaient se
reconnaissaient à nouveau et c'est
impossible de ne pas continuer ce truc
là celle aventure d'artistes pas
d'habitants artistes qui produisent leur
propre récit et du récit pour leur ville
et leur territoire et des récits que les
artistes vont partager à maurepas pour
une représentation unique
[Musique]
le festival du film documentaire saint
quentin vous met la tête dans les
étoiles
thème de cette quatrième édition
l'espace un choix pas anodin pour notre
territoire un mot de loro mazaury le
président de tv 78 il ya un objectif de
montrer que ce qui vient de l'espace
nous touchent au quotidien
beaucoup des progrès scientifiques la
téléphonie mobile
les travaux sur les small size par
exemple sont directement dérivés y
compris des travaux d'apollo de l'époque
il nous semblait logique de travailler
sur cet espace qui est bien génère
beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois sur le
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
ça c'est pour la partie à dire purement
économique mais également on est tous
des petits garçons et petites filles qui
avons dès notre plus jeune âge lever les
yeux pour regarder les avions levé les
yeux pour regarder les les fusées et
donc ça parle au grand public sa parade
où tous plusieurs jours de projections
de documentaires mais aussi de films des
expositions des ateliers des conférences
et de nombreux sites partenaires du
festival parmi eux le cinéma ugc skyway
son directeur est avec nous marc albaut
gravasses bonjour bonjour les festivals
des buts même chez vous puisque vous
accueillez la soirée d'ouverture
tout à fait maintenant c'est une petite
tradition depuis maintenant la quatrième
année que nous faisons le festival donc
nous accueillons demain soir la soirée
d'inauguration qui commencera par
l'émission animée par patrice carmouze
pas fan friends avec quatre invités qui
vont parler un petit peu de la place de
l'homme dans l'espace et c'est donc et
ça c'est précédé par un petit moment
musical par l'école de musique de
montigny-le-bretonneux
donc voilà donc on a une belle soirée
d'inauguration qui commence demain
il reste quelques places pour ceux qui
sont intéressés n'hésitez pas à vous
donne à vous inscrire il faut s'inscrire
sur le site du festival
la soirée va réserver des surprises où
l'on rentre doucement dans le thème de
l'année alors le on va on va rentrer
progressivement parce que voilà on a
décidé avec l' orchestre de l'école de
musique de montigny de faire des thèmes
célèbres
notamment de filmer tout pour ne pas
faire pas mal de petites choses donc
voila et puis après on veut entamer le
débat animé par patrice carmouze et
j'espère qu'il y aura aussi les
interactions avec la salle mais ça ce
n'est que la soirée d'inauguration
et oui parce qu'il ya aussi une soirée
temps x alors un nom de soi et qui va
sans doute raviver des souvenirs chez
certains de nos téléspectateurs
on a quelques années en arrière oui
alors voilà je pense que pose pour tous
les gens notamment de ma génération
autant x c'est un moment privilégié de
découverte de l'espace de découverte du
cosmos etc et on a la chance d'avoir les
frères bogdanoff jeudi soir là aussi
qu'ils vont nous montrer un documentaire
qu'ils ont confectionnées sur l'espace
ils vont près pouvoir le public
interagir avec eux dans la salle donc je
pense que ça va être un vrai moment est
à la fois nostalgie est justement de
comprendre par des choses simples
comment la place de l'homme dans
l'espace et c'est donc je pensais pas
être en très bon moment là aussi les
places sont rares donc n'hésitez pas à
vous inscrire parce qu'il reste que très
peu de place
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est la
quatrième année que je participe au
festival pour la quatrième édition
vous avez un attachement tout
particulier aux films documentaires
écoutez ça permet aussi au public de
découvrir autre chose que des
blockbusters ou de films de genre d'art
et essai c'est une autre façon de faire
du cinéma du documentaire donc c'est
intéressant de montrer un autre public
une autre facette du cinéma et notamment
dans de très bonnes conditions dans des
salles de cinéma le thème vous
personnellement l'espace la science
fiction un genre qui vous plaît alors
moi j'ai une prédilection importante par
rapport à ce thème et puis je pense que
inconsciemment même ceux qui n'y sont
pas vraiment porté dessus on se dit est
ce qu'il ya quelqu'un d'autre avec nous
dans ce vaste univers donc ça ça
remémore plein de choses en nous et je
pense que c'est un thème qui n'a pas été
facile à mettre à orchestrer parce que
ce seront des reboot ya beaucoup de
films de suez mais les documentaires
sont plus rares créer des événements
c'est aussi peu compliqué mais voilà je
pense qu'on a créé un beau festival avec
beaucoup d'animations et je vais revenir
dans quelques instants
sauf que l'actualité sur l'espace a été
très présente thomas pesquet dans notre
souris alors dans votre cinéma tous les
films en compétition sont diffusées par
tous les documentaires les documentaires
travers en compétition seront diffusés
je vous le rappelle pour ceux qui
veulent le voir la programmation est
affiché à l'ugc et l'accès est gratuit
d'accord donc c'est aussi un moyen de
découvrir des documentaires sur l'espace
il y aurait télescope intérieur il y
aura plein de documentaires sur sur sur
le thème de l'espace donc n'hésitez pas
à vous avez le programme qui s'affiche
dans le hall du cinéma et c'est en accès
libre
donc ça aussi c'est très intéressant et
tout serait plus exact en place alors le
festival fait voyager pas seulement
travers des documentaires cinéma
défaisance et des films c'est le cas du
veau du grenier à sel de trappes est
signé sept d'elancourt et vous
particulièrement il ya pas mal de
classiques
oui on a voulu ben voilà on reprendre le
des grands classiques du cinéma donc on
va on va reprendre les quelques aliens
quelques star trek
on va reprendre des films un peu plus
modernes comme gravity comme
interstellar comme l'odyssée de l'espace
je veux dire la référence voilà ça tiens
on va le rediffuser naturellement ton
voilà donc on a voulu un choix avec de
la modernité comme interstellaire et
gravity mais de revenir aussi sur le
premier star trek sur les aliens on peut
même faire la différence des difficiles
le premier est notamment le dernier de
2009 dit tellement donc voilà donc ils
les gens vont pouvoir avoir un choix et
de documentaires et de films assez large
alors autour du festival on en a mis
quelques mots tout à l'heure il ya ce
qu'on peut appeler un oeuf
il ya des ateliers des conférences chez
vous on va parler philo et on va pouvoir
voyager
voilà d'ocré on a voulu créer aussi tout
un thème autour de l'espace parce que
c'est quand même notre thème de ce
festival
donc dès dès samedi et dimanche nous
allons monter dans le hall de l'ugc un
planétarium où les gens pourront en
voilà pendant 45 minutes avec un
animateur s'immerger dans l'espace donc
là aussi ce sont des séances d'une
quinzaine de personnes maximum qui
peuvent rentrer dans le planétarium donc
là aussi inscrivez vous parce que les
places sont assez limitées mais vous
avez quatre sessions le samedi
après-midi et quatre le dimanche en plus
de ça on a voulu aussi élargir pour les
plus petits pour les 8 10 ans on va dire
avec la mise en place d'un goûter philo
donc là aussi le thème sera à la place
de l'homme et où on en est dans
l'univers autour d'un goûter qui se
tiendra vers 15h ou 16h dans le hall de
l'ugeci une belle programmation merci
marcal bangré vaise alors je le rappelle
vous êtes le directeur du cinéma ugc
skywest est l'un des partenaires du
festival saint quentin le festival
démarre ce mercredi 28 novembre avec une
soirée d'ouverture et tout le programme
est à retrouver sur le site internet
[Musique]
douze albums pour découvrir la guerre
sous un autre angle à saint cyr l'école
c'est la bande dessinée qui raconte la
grande guerre les dessins de poilus à
ceux de dessinateurs professionnels
l'histoire est retranscrite
on peut découvrir delphine prier maillot
et aurélien ducoudray qui raconte les
gueules cassées l'art ce n'est qui
décrypte la une de front et bien sûr
tardy sur la guerre des tranchées
l'exposition est à découvrir dans le
hall de l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au 15
décembre
c'est un peu ludique c'est plutôt
d'allemandes décider si l'image d'epinal
pour montrer au niveau des enfants les
enfants pour leur expliquer un peu la
guerre les soldats pour la première
exposition tout est plutôt pour les
quatorze essais entre temps qu'ils ont
dit on va faire un thème sur la bande
dessinée aussi pour la vire 14
notre vision layar 14 peut-être plus
pour les jeunes dans les yvelines
environ 500 édifices sont protégés au
titre des monuments historiques des
bâtiments qui contiennent près de 2400
oeuvres protégées et quelques 6000
édifice objets eux ne sont pas protégés
un patrimoine qui est à la charge des
communes pour la conservation et la
restauration l'agency généré lancé par
le département accompagne ces communes
le dernier chantier de l'année 2018
après fin il ya quelques jours à côté de
sartrouville
l'occasion de découvrir cette mission
il reprend sa place dans l'église saint
martin ce tableau du 16e siècle a été
retrouvé en 2017 dans le presbytère de
la paroisse de sartrouville
on sait que ce tableau étaient présents
dans l'église saint martin alors 1906
puisqu'il y a eu un inventaire réalisé à
l'époque par le curé et par vos
prédécesseurs battre au maire à l'époque
en 1906 mais nous ignorons son origine
une restauration possible grâce à l'
agence un générique lancée en 2014 par
le département
elle s'occupe de sauvegarde et de
transmission du patrimoine depuis
janvier 2018 plus particulièrement au
patrimoine des communes et des communes
rurales en particulier
évidemment ce patrimoine concernent pour
l'essentiel le patrimoine religieux
puisque c'est le principalement dans les
églises que nous avons effectivement les
objets dont nous nous occupons
aujourd'hui pour simplifier les objets
dont nous occupons ne sont pas des
objets qui se trouvent dans des musées
voilà pour faire un petit peu la
distinction mais c'est plutôt les objets
qui sont parfois protégés d'ailleurs au
titre des monuments historiques de sites
permettent la conservation dont un
atelier au sein des archives
départementales pour le tableau
sartrouville ya dix mois de restauration
ont été nécessaires trois professionnels
se sont penchés sur l'oeuvre la dernière
et a mis la touche finale au mois
d'octobre
la grande question était de savoir s'il
y avait puisque toutes été repeints s'il
y avait de la peinture originale en
dessous donc les tests ont permis de
dégager et de voir que la peinture au
dessous étaient présentes qu'elles
étaient très usés mais qu'elle était
présente
il va partir d'abord chez grant wahl
heures pour un premier pic sage il va
revenir pour le nettoyage et
l'enlèvement des repeints et après
l'enlèvement dé leur pain il repart dans
un atelier dure en toile heures qui va
procéder au doublage ou hors entoilage
du tableau lui m il revient
ici pour pour procéder alors en
retouchera la réintégration
les restaurations sont faites à la
demande des communes mais aussi parfois
d'ingénérie une dizaine de projets
concernent des objets chaque année ce
week-end c'est le retour du salon du
livre d'elancourt la commanderie
accueille sa deuxième édition plus de 70
auteurs sont attendus
deux d'entre eux sont en plateau avec
nous bernard delattre et bernard menez
bonjour à tous les deux bonjour alors
déjà perdre en vitesse je me tourne vers
vous donc on vous connais comme comédien
vous êtes aussi auteur pourquoi déjà
avoir répondu à l'invitation des
organisateurs a tout simplement parce
que c'est un livre extrêmement récent
qui a été fait en collaboration avec
carole wrona qui est une écrivain
formidable un grand talent qui
d'ailleurs y recharger
j'étais à une projection de elle
travaille pour arte elle a fait un
reportage sur damian sur sur les que les
grandes dames de l'entre-deux-guerres et
elle m'a écrit on s'est vus pendant deux
ans et elle a pris des notes et où elle
m'a proposé son écriture qui est j'ai
l'impression que c'est exactement ce que
je voulais dire
sauf que c'est très bien de vie est
beaucoup mieux que si j'avais fait moi
même et là sur ce salon est ce que alors
vous allez tout dire à vos lecteurs vous
avez encore garder un petit peu de
secrets alors il ya deux raisons pour
lesquelles je ne peux pas dire tous la
première c'est que il ya des gens dont
je pourrais parler mais ils sont encore
vivants et si je dis ce que je pense ça
va saigner donc j'en parle pas et la
deuxième c'est si il fallait tout dire
ce que ce que j'avais envie de dire où
tout et anecdotes c'est s'arrêter le
double alors il faut pas il faut laisser
les lecteurs un peu sur la fin
et puis pas les assommer avec un nombre
de pages et un autre un autre ouvrage
plus tard peut-être peut-être mais je
suis pas pressé bernard delattre est en
fait aussi partie de l'organisation du
salon l'an dernier il y avait 2000
visiteurs qui avaient répondu présent à
ce que vous espérez le même nombre cette
année on espère faire mieux
garda g20 son livre je me suis régalé je
conseille vraiment à tout le monde j'ai
cerné un très beau cadeau de noël
oui et c'est on revit toutes nos jeux
avec sèche 16 pages de photos qui
retracent le livrer nos logiquement
c'est vraiment un très bon et donc il a
nous invité d'honneur est le grand a été
noircie jean françois kahn quoi jean
françois kahn qui le parrain et qui la
sort de deux livres j'ai en tout la vie
de victor hugo on love s'empale ayant et
sans les discours de 1850 enfin ces
phénomènes il explique le parcours de
victor hugo
comment il est devenu un royaliste à un
républicain et son dernier livre qui
s'appelle la lettonne qui permet de tout
dire
n comme nazi bien sûr vers la remercie
donc cela il a remarqué que la lettre de
m
permettait de l'om il ya malraux
mitterrand mao marx c'est incroyable
tous deux médailles sonia plomb
justement cette année il ya un fil rouge
quand même l'histoire et autour de
l'évolution c'est ça l'évolution
de la communication le grand lcd pille
on veut des pigeons voyageurs au
numérique
pigeon voyageur ce centenaire de 14-18
fin de la guerre 1918 et on a à michel
jarre qui est déficient le roi qui a
fait un livre sur les animaux de la
grande guerre et il parle des pigeons
voyageurs mais aussi des chevaux il ya
un million de chevaux français qui ont
été tués des chiens il ya eu des chiens
de traîneaux qu'on est allé chercher
haut qu'au québec c'est toute une
histoire et raconte tout ça et on a
aussi un jeune françois belley qui va
nous parler café des livres sur le
numérique
le son le thème de sa conférence ça va
être le la maîtrise du virtuel le
le défi du xxième siècle l'agent
flattant le président des amis du passé
l'association qui organise le salon avec
l'aide de la mairie et l'agglomération
de saint quentin lui va nous parler de
la dernière offensive de 1918 et jean
françois kahn à faire sa grande
conférence à 14h30 sur victor hugo et
ensuite il va embrayer après 15h sur mm
la maudite la lettre qui permet de tout
programmation ce qu'il ya plusieurs
conférences bernard menez j'imagine
qu'un salon c'est toujours très attendu
ça permet des contrées de rencontres et
d'échangés sur l'ouvragé depuis et le
livre est sorti il ya un an et demi et
depuis j'ai fait beaucoup de salons dont
cette fameuse forêt des livres de qui
nous a quittés pour un accident on dit
oui et c'est vrai que 2 brice ne nous
devons axer brisson axe aux accents
british qui était une fois vous
connaissez dans la forêt des livres
c'est un tout l'extra ordinaire dans un
lieu dans le loiret et c'est vrai que
chaque salon ben j'y vais de toute façon
avec grande fierté parce que pour le
moment c'est le seul qui existe sur moi
il ya personne d'autre et donc si je
meurs demain jj un accident il vaut cher
il est là bas et je vais vous dire il
alla il vaudra cher
mais j'en suis très fier les gens que
ceux qui l'ont lu ont la même réaction
que bernard delattre et ils me disent
qu'ils auraient killy qui sont étonné
surpris par ce que il y en a qui le
lisent mais de deux boutons bouger sans
s'arrêter
bernard est un personnage étonnant vous
savoir qu'il était professeur de maths y
de mathématiques qui le pilote d'avion
qu'il a abandonné pour la presse il est
aussi dans le président des polymusclés
de l'olp qui travaillent pour les
handicapés raisonnée pour les handicaps
pas là et je suis aussi au conseil
d'administration de l'adami
mons et les droits des artistes et
musiciens interprètes le bernard
delattre plus de 70 auteurs en deux
saisons comment on va les chercher ses
hôtes rbc sur les salons je fais
beaucoup de salons sur un peu auteurs
affaires depuis dix ans je fais des
livres je fais beaucoup de salons et on
connaît plein de gens
on prend les adresses avec bernard on a
sympathisé tout de suite voilà
et donc voilà et puis sur le thème du
salon leur dis tiens ça vous
intéresserait
mais c'est toujours en fonction de la
date quoi l'appareil devait y avoir
patrice franceschi capitaine du trois
mâts la vidéo ce qui devait venir et
nous a fait faux bond parce qu'il a il
part en mission avec bernard kouchner
vous savez que verdun et prendre ses
skis par hilali a dû partir au kurdistan
syrien vous savez qui se bat pour les
kurdes les pauvres kurdes qui sont
complètement broyé par lecture par
d'achille il faut les aider et patrice
sanchez qui va sur le terrain mais
l'arrivée il y avait une opportunité d'y
aller avec vers leur kouchner donc il a
dit suis vraiment désolé pour cent mais
l'an prochain il sera là bas on fera du
personnel c'est de cette façon là que ça
se passait derrière moi j'ai fait pas
mal de salon parce que j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un qui ait vu dans un salon
gilliam j'ai le mien j'aimerais bien que
vous veniez aussi ont bien voilà c'est
comme un brin région qui se crée comme
ça on a beaucoup parlé de littérature
plutôt pour les adultes mais vous
n'oubliez pas les jeunes
ils encourent notamment bénédicte de
graisse et jean-philippe maison qui oui
c'est ça york au rayon jeunesse avec le
libraire 17 marins michel fourré le
toute son équipe qu'ils ont on a
amplifié le rayon jeunesse avec une
valeur d'auteurs jeunesse peut visionner
enfants adolescents en bande dessinée
ils auront beaucoup de place dans la
chapelle y aura georges gras rossi qui a
fait beaucoup de bandes dessinées dont
une bande dessinée la banda aide qui a
eu le prix handi livre nationale et tout
mais dans les conférences d'oublier tout
à l'heure il ya gérard dardy qui est
très connu aussi qui nous parlera de de
gaulle à travers le xxème siècle de
gaulle à un acteur phénoménale des deux
guerres mondiales quoi et à quel niveau
héros des deux guerres mondiales gens
malheureusement
coupe et on a un peu pris par le temps
mais le plus simple pour rencontrer tous
ces auteurs c'est de se rendre au salon
du livre d'elancourt c'est le dimanche
de décembre c'est à la commanderie
merci à tous les deux de très bonnes
choses sur ce plateau littérature encore
salon du livre en corse que le week-end
dernier c'était le salon histoire de
lire à versailles un rendez vous qui
attire près de vingt mille personnes
cent soixante dix auteurs sont venus à
la rencontre des vecteurs et parmi eux
un versailles et récemment primé camille
pascal s'est vu décerner le grand prix
du roman de l'académie française pour
l'été des quatre rois il était au micro
de marie line et yapi chez nous c'est un
talent particulier parce que c'est le
grand prix du roman de l'académie
française qui a couronné m'ont été des
quatre rois et que c'est un prix
extrêmement impressionnant dans la
mesure où ils me place dans la lignée
très prestigieuse d'auteurs dont je me
considère aujourd'hui comme l'héritier
et on passe maintenant à notre page
agenda
[Musique]
on ouvre notre page agenda avec du
cinéma est le dernier film du
réalisateur versailles et frédéric
tellier après la police judiciaire le
monde des pompiers sauver ou périr vous
emmène à la rencontre de franquin
sapeurs pompiers de paris qui se
sacrifient lors d'un incendie
le film sort dans les salles ce mercredi
28 novembre à l'extrême j'aimais l'idée
que ce métier
puis-je me rendre fort invincible nous
sortons maintenir
m
[Musique]
tc que personne étant un sigle pénétrer
dans des ateliers de gravure art gravure
à 50 ans levin vous ouvre ses portes ce
week-end l'association exposera les
créations de ses adhérents et échangera
sur les différentes techniques
enseignées rendez-vous dans leurs
ateliers
les concerts de mélanie de biasio se
font selon leurs roses sont ressentis et
l'artiste aime improviser le 1er
décembre elle sera sur la scène du
prisme d'elancourt pour son dernier
album on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
just not dead
'nos les deux
ce fait
chance
[Musique]
du cirque nostalgique à présent dans une
maison de campagne il faut prendre des
décisions il faut la vider
il faut trier garder ou se séparer
d'affaires cinq acrobates déballent
leurs valises à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt regarder
[Musique]
en 1969 l'homme marchait sur la lune au
son de pink floyd
le groupe britannique était invité par
la bbc a accompagné musicalement
l'alunissage d'apollo 11
à la même époque de nouveaux modèles de
synthétiseurs débarque sur le marché des
faits marquants qui ont inspiré thierry
balasse l'artiste vous emmène dans
l'espace au son des artistes de l'époque
les pink floyd bien sûr david bowie ou
encore les beatles
[Musique]
ah ah
ans
ensemble ils ont créé de grands
standards joueur de blues lucile ou
encore la boîte de jazz michel jonasz et
jean-yves d'angélo ce livre sur scène
dans un piano voix ils sont sur la scène
du théâtre espace coluche de plaisir
[Musique]
bah
nousty bleus
c'est le the blues
[Musique]
nous
c'est tout
c'est nous
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce cette culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
nous